Look,
it's unbelievably widespread.
So I'll give you an example that's very,
that's very similar.
Our Prime Minister,
Justin Trudeau announced in 2015 that half the cabinet that he put together
would be women,
right?
The fact that only approximately,
I think it was 20 to 25% of the elected officials were female.
And so what he basically admitted,
as far as I'm concerned,
it was two things.
Number one,
he was incapable of judging people on their competence because when you put
together something like the cabinet for a country,
what you do is you find the most competent people period.
Because
it's so bizarre that it even has to be said because it actually turns out that
the cabinet is important.
And so to me all he did was default on his cell is central moral obligation to
screen every single one of his members of parliament with exceeding care and to
pick the most qualified people.
And his rationale was that it was 2015 you know,
so,
and we to reduce competence to racial,
ethnic,
gender identity,
something like that is an absolutely appalling move.
Philosophically as well,
as far as I'm concerned,
to assume that diversity is somehow represented by group membership.
There's no evidence for that.
There's absolutely no scientific evidence for that whatsoever.
In fact,
the scientific evidence suggests quite the contrary,
which is about,
there's more variability within groups than there is between groups,
which is actually an antidote to the central racist claim,
right.
Because the central racist claim is,
there's more difference between groups than there is difference within them.
And so,
you know,
you seen one black person,
you've seen them all.